l'aventuré xxl de noël
mood cars à noël fait la connaissance
allez countach s de crise
le réalisateur de l'âge de glace c'est
quand ces trucs des super intelligent il
adore se cacher là dedans
on entend par un drôle de bruit c'est un
monstre qui vise autant qu'à pôle est
censé faire comme bruit
préparez vous à vivre
oui
une aventure déjantée
j'ai tu fabriques en france toile à
temps et une amitié dépendantes
garde ça quoi
mais non
je suis multi conduit lui ou moi
monster cars
touchette apathique le 21 décembre au
cinéma
un trip salut sam
tu peux avoir un truc de ouf je te dis
pas mon père la tête qui fait on n'a
jamais rien vu de pareil sérieux
habitants de la région ont déclaré avoir
aperçu une créature des spectacles on
cherche quelque chose d'inhabituel et de
dangereux
mais quoi toi il m'arrive un truc se
voir même droit comment t'expliquer
jette un oeil
il adore se cacher la torre il est cool
et hyper doué il sert de moteur à moka
car c'est bien ça crée de tulle a appuyé
critique tu crois tu peux me battre
ça
tu te demande pas d'où il vient
je vais être amené chez toi loin de ce
qu'ils cherchent si je t'aime laisse-moi
perçoit mieux la route que toi
pas par là surtout chez son ami trip ces
messieurs veulent te parler que j'ai pas
envie de vous suivre là tu m'as forcée
on a vraiment fait ça carrément ouais je
suis chercheur et je peux vous aider
c'est une famille il faut quoi des
quatre cadres dont tu roulais encore à
vélo il ya pas huit jours
pour maîtriser mis leur ceinture
okc reach à table j'adore ta caisse
merci
waouh